it all cups it all comes from this 1990
World Championship match and these guys
Garry Kasparov at the defending world
champion against Anatoly Karpov hated
each other's guts I mean even though
they both came from the Soviet Union and
we like to think of the Soviet Union to
some marvelously wonderful tallit Aryan
state where you know everybody marched
to the drum of the state in truth no no
no these guys really really hated one
another I think in their career they
played something like 130 odd world
championship games tournament games
against one another and Gary had like an
advantage of two points out of all of
their matches like they really really
played each other they played five World
Championship matches this match was from
their fifth this game was from their
fifth World Championship match and this
is like Ali Frazier out whoops
Ali Frazier had three fantastic fights
this was their fifth this match this
game would determine the winner of the
match Gary Kasparov was white open e for
classical Rui Lopez and Anatoly Karpov
played a seven a sex in those days
Anatoly Karpov had a massive team of
seconds and trainers and coaches and
grandmasters including one by the name
of Igor Zaitsev Zaitsev created his own
opening defensive system as black called
the sights that variation the Zaitsev
defense in the Rui Lopez Karpov had been
the Zaitsev defense for literally his
whole career and in this world
championship match where the players
have spent months preparing for for one
another it is no it's absolute certainty
to say that Anatoly Karpov would play
the sites have defense so far what has
happened in the opening is we have a
very very standard series of moves that
that have been played in the Rui Lopez
for the better part of a hundred years
c2 c3 and all of these moves have been
played in countless thousands of
Grandmaster games this move h2 h3 just
deserves a little explanation what white
wants to do white wants to play the move
d2 oops sorry just a second d to d4 hold
on where's my tab yeah there we go B to
d4 and to get a nice what we say Center
pawn duo these pawns on e4 or d4 and e4
or conversely 'if I've and d5 are
considered a major strategic advantage
for the player who can achieve the
center pawn duo the problem with making
this advance right away is that if we
play d4 then the problem is that this
bishop comes to g4 pins the knight to
the Queen
the knight is an important protector of
this pawn on d4 and so practice again
thousands of games of practice has shown
the efficacy of the move h2 h3 even
though we spend a tempo we stop this
move Bishop g4 again these are all very
standard moves Bishop d7
d4 rook TA
ninety-two bishop fa the combination of
these two moves of bishop to f8 and
Bishop to b7 really is what the Zaitsev
variation is all about what black is
trying to do is by using his rook on e8
his knight on f6 as well as his bishop
on b7 if he really wants to put a lot of
pressure on this center pawn on e4 the
game continued a2 a4 in my earlier
lecture in the beginners class I was
saying that in the opening do make an
effort to avoid creating weaknesses on
the flanks and that on a higher
sophisticated level the idea of pawn
structure is an important element with
this move a for what white is trying to
do is isolate this pawn on b5 and to
create a weakness on the B Phi squared
all of these moves still have been
played in the past and we haven't yet
come to a key moment but with this move
h7 h6 basically what black is asking
white is how are you going to develop
your Queen side pieces as soon as this
Knight moves black intends to capture on
d4 and capture this pawn on e4 so it's
not easy for white to move if he moves
this night he'll lose this pawn but if
he doesn't move the knight this Bishop
remains passive Gary played Bishop c2
which is a main main line in the Zaitsev
so finally one two three defenders of
the pawn on e4 and white is ready to
move his knight and to open up the
diagonal for his Bishop all of these
moves have been played before
takes tanks night to be four again and
the sights f we see this Bishop coming
alive and we're this night coming to be
for the bishop on c2 is attacked Gary
drop back his Bishop with Bishop c2 to
be one c7 c5 d 4 D 5
so finally white now has a grip in the
center and these pawns on d5 and E 4 are
very good they block out this Bishop on
b7 in fact these pawns are so good it's
vital it's vital for black to put as
much pressure on these Center pawns as
possible if he doesn't put up pressure
immediately on the center pawns white is
going to have a massive spatial
advantage Knight d7 now the idea behind
this move Knight d7
is to prepare the advanced f7 f5 as soon
as the pawn comes to f5 the oops excuse
me these two pawns on e4 and on d5 are
going to come under pressure when black
gets in that freeing move f5 in the
meanwhile this guy this work on a1 it's
not doing anything how to get that rook
into the game Gary did what we call a
rook lift
he brought his rook up to the 3rd rank
and moved it over this game I've dubbed
lightning and thunder or thunder and
lightning what we're what we're going to
see is it kind of just unfolds before
our eyes is we all know that we that
checkmate ends the game hey you got to
do is checkmate your opponent you win
and we start the game with this
wonderful concept we just got a check
made our opponent but somehow we never
get to
our opponent checkmates us first and
what we from this position what we're
going to see is what the University of
Southern California Trojans and a
football play may call student body
right all of Wight's pieces are gonna go
after blacks King but you got him the
new room over there to get to blacks
King and we're gonna say an amazing
thunder and lightning coming on blacks
King Anatole continued with his strategy
of pressuring white in the center white
moved over with his rooks rook on a 3-2
III so now these rooks are very nicely
doubled up on the e-file and they have
threats down the e-file so what Gary
also wants to do is he wants to win this
pawn on f7 moved to the square F fight
it weakened the square e sinks so Gary
has an idea that one day he wants to
plant a piece on the e6 grim the game
continued Knight f6 so anatoly's idea is
he wants to capture this pawn and after
the knight recaptures he wants to
capture this pawn up to now remarkably
enough these two players are in what
they call their preparation that is to
say literally after weeks and months of
working on positions and trying to
figure out the nuances both players had
this position at home and Gary played an
incredibly amazing for me novelty that
really really
hit a fantastic chord with me this blue
night h2 on the face of it appears
without sense if you were to ask me I
would say that this knight on f3 stands
pretty good it's on a good square why
did he move Knight to h2 what Gary's
idea was was that he wants this rook to
slide over to g3 so that it would square
up with blacks King also Gary had in
mind that this knight on h2 could one
day jump to the g4 square and also get
after blacks King black didn't really
have too much of a choice
oh pardon me he did have a big choice
here at this exact moment he had a very
big choice I had expected
Anatoli to capture this pawn Knight
captures Knight captures rook here now
after the move rook to g3 comes White's
idea he sacrificed a pawn but he wants
to play Bishop takes h6 the bishop could
not be recaptured because the pawn on g7
is pinned by this rook so what Anatoli
did in the game was he moved his king in
anticipation of this variation but let's
look at it a few more moves out what
would have happened in this position
after room g3 what Anatoli did not like
was that when the King moves to h6 he
didn't want to see white play the move
Knight to g4 in his mind
he couldn't see a way of preventing
white from playing Knight takes h6
followed by Bishop takes h6 a sacrifice
of two pieces
followed by Queen to h5 in other words
he was like no no this is too much
firepower being thrown against me and
after Knight h2 he moved his King okay
Gary continued b2 b3 and this it's like
one of those things you know in in
sports and I love sports you know you
see a play a baseball play you know a
double play and it's like snap snap pow
and it happened so fast
and you see this action and you're
thrilled by this action I'm a tiny
little move like b2 b3 does not send the
crowd and it's a great display of all
times but it is in this case essentially
all of whites pieces are gonna go after
blacks King except this bishop on c1 a
moment ago it was attacking this pawn on
h6 followed by a rook g3 with this move
b2 b3 Gary brings everybody to the party
Gary imagines that this Bishop is going
to slide to the long diagonal on b2 and
at the end of the rainbow as blacks King
b2 b3 of a very very nice little move
that makes an enormous difference
captures captures Anatoli played the
move c5 c4 so what Anatoly is doing with
this move is he's anticipating that one
day he can bring a knight to d3 and
block up black White's attack
Gary says fine let's go
Bishop to b2 bringing the bishop to a
great diagonal and Anatoly finally them
at long last captured the pawn so
White's Center is all dissolved did you
have a question yeah sure of course
which world here after c4 yes a very
good question fair enough
why didn't white simply capture the C
pawn because then after takes should we
take on e4 with Bishop yes oh well we'll
just see so what happens is at the end
of this very very long series of very
forcing captures look at this you get to
this position and if you count all the
material it's actually pretty balanced
so there was there would just be this
massive series of take steak steak steak
steak steak steaks and at the end of the
day Gary was not satisfied that he would
have enough of an advantage so that was
a very good question thank you very much
for that question by the way and that
was why he played Bishop e2 takes Knight
takes Knight takes rook g3 and now here
we go
look at black pieces compares to White's
in the first place this rook on a a
hasn't moved in the second the Queen
hasn't moved but from White's
perspective he's ready to go Queen h1
Queen takes h6 Shaq thanks to the pin on
the diagonal a moment ago there was a
pin on the file now it's turned to a pin
on the diagonal okay
Anatoli plays rook yi six so the move
rookie six the idea is
that he wants to meet queen h5
protecting the pond and being able to
play Queen to e8 so very nice defensive
move Knight g4 involving everybody
bringing everybody to the party so now
white is attacking with two bishops
two rooks two knights and as we'll see
in a moment this Queen Knight g4 Anatoly
played the move Queen e8 which looks
very very attractive and it's the
follow-up of his previous turn
so with this move Queenie aid Anatoly
doubles up on the e-file and in his
mind's eye
it means this knight is pinned and that
can't move the knight moves rook takes
Eve one check and resigns so the Queen
also a moment ago remember I was
pointing out there was a line or two
where whites Queen could come to the h5
square so with the MU queenie 8 he rules
out any invasions with queen h5 and at
the same time once again doubles up
against the knight on e4 and out of the
words whites whites blacks not going
down without a fight
he's putting up a very spirited defense
9 takes a 6 bang take that take taking
upon now you of course you cannot take
with the pawn because that would be
illegal the bishop pins well can't we
just pardon me couldn't we just take the
knight
what would what would white have done if
we hit if he had taken the night don't
rush out and shout at once to assist
myself I brought with me my book winning
chess brilliant C's it's a it's a book
that I wrote years ago and in fact I
wrote it for men min-ye and I dedicated
to him with thanks for all of his port
not support but portal he had an
extensive port cellar I should say in
case of in case of rook takes h6
what Anatoly did not like was Knight
takes d6 the Knight attacks the Queen
Ruth pardon me
the Knight attacks the Queen the bishop
and this rook also attacks the Queen
Knight takes D 6 and in case you take
with the rook then rook takes rook takes
check attacks MacLean and also this rook
so you can't take with the rook if you
move the Queen Queen to d7 this is the
main move Knight pops back to f5 now the
knight on f5 attacks the rook as well as
this pawn notice that all of White's
pieces are bearing down on the pawn on
g7 that's really a pile up rook h7 the
player saw this whole variation and here
White has a fantastic move this did not
happen in the game it's a sub variation
of what could have happened what's a
really
move for white now again a moment ago I
just pointed out that everything is
hitting g7 with this move how else could
we hit g7 young man yes Queen g4 is a
very very good move the problem is is
that black has his own ideas too the
problem is there's that black he wants
to play the move c3 to block this bishop
right so Queen g4 looks really
attractive except that see three blocks
White's attack the move that the the
players both saw was rook d7 boom rook
d7 what a wild move and in case of
Bishop takes c7 rook takes g7 rook takes
g7 Queen h5 check the King has to go to
g8
Knight f6 check nothing
oops sorry check check
checkmate
this final the position where they black
king is completely denuded right I mean
is just goes to show what a fabulous
attack White has created here so after
Knight takes h6
Anatoly did not capture he saw this
variation I'll go through it again
this is that one and there is this one
Queen d7 attack oops not Queen g4 that
rookie seven
you cannot capture the the rook with the
night because if you do that black would
lose his Queen and again if you capture
with a queen I'll take your queen so
Knight takes h6 Anatoly played c4 c3
okay any guesses as to what white played
no way okay he's not going into the
vision you got that one right - too slow
no this is lightning and thunder and
crackling and storm clouds everything
this is a tough one again I was in Lyon
at the time watch yes you know rook
takes c3 mm-hmm look at that and young
man you had also a suggestion
Knight f7 or sorry okay if Knight f7
check I can just take that night the
other move was Bishop takes c3 rook
takes c3 I'm sorry
so rook takes c3 I think now black can
get away with rook takes h6 because you
didn't have the variations that you had
the last time so this is a little bit of
a hard one to see but white this
basically said okay I'll come back with
my knight go ahead and take my bishop
Knight f5 see takes B - okay so white
sacrifices a whole piece and now white
plays Queen g4 so with this move white
is angling for an opportunity to play
Queen h4 check and maybe Knight f6 or
maybe Knight g5 and don't forget that
this bishop on b1 also radiates and if
white could ever play Queen h4 check in
Queen h7 it could be checkmate
so Queen g4 look at whites powerful
our me building up Bishop to c8 okay so
what
oops excuse me so what Anatole is hoping
is that he can use his bishop to be able
to trade for either the night or even
capture the Queen that would be the best
of all worlds Queen h4 check King oops
sorry
cancel no cancel King g8y in the game
Anatole played rook h6 what why didn't
he play oops sorry
Queen h4 King GB can you tell me why he
didn't play King g8 night h6 check that
is right Knight h6 check rook takes h6
oops sorry Queen takes h6 and now you're
threatening Knight f6 check you're
threatening mates on h7 f 6 g7 and
there's basically no moves in case of
Queen f7 okay I want you guys to see
this one what would you have done
against Queen s other young men Knight
g5 I'll take your queen 90 then the move
Knight g5 blocks thee where else could
you move your night beside g5
yes I heard it take on d6 now this night
attacks blacks Queen but white is also
threatening queen h7 checkmate Bishop
takes now I want you to think a moment
what's a good move for white now that's
a good move is there a better move dish
and bit the hill move is king I mean we
could take as Bishop with you yes I
heard it
rook e8 check if you take the rook it's
checkmate on g7 if you block the rook
with your bishop it's checkmate on hm
whoa very nice beautiful variations okay
let me just see why isn't in this moment
Queen h7 check
you can youuuu win the Queen but okay
it's kind of running away a little bit I
don't know
yes but it's nice it's nice
okay so in this position Queen check
rook h6 okay
garry kasparov white to play Knight
takes h6g takes h6 and now this was a
very very nice move we talked about the
elements in King position Gary played
the move king h2 basically what Gary
would love to do is he left it like
doesn't that happen to you as well that
you would love to make two moves in at
once and your opponent won't let you
so Gary would love to play the move
Knight f6 followed by rook g8 check and
mate the problem it with Knight f6 is
Queen takes II one comes with check so
with this move king h2
gary is preparing Knight to f6 and
followed by root 2 g8 mate okay so King
h2 and now comes Queen B five a very
good defensive move blacks Queen
protects protects the f6 Square and puts
the rook on g3 in a pin and covers the
fifth-ranked as well
Knight g5 okay
an attack oops I keep doing that
I apologize attacking blacks Queen if
black takes the rook Knight f7 is check
and mate yeah so you can't take the rook
Queen drop back to f6
so Queen f6 protects the f7 square so
there's no Knight f7 mate Gary played
rook e8 pinning the well invading the
eighth-ranked and pinning the bishop on
f8 okay so White's idea is let's say
black makes a move I'm not sure what a
good move is let's say black makes a
move just like this then White's ideas
to go Queen takes check is that pretty
so to stop this
Anatoli played Bishop f5 and now a very
funny thing happened it's like white has
sacrificed remember he sacrificed his
Bishop on b2 and in the next few moves
it's like Gary wins a box full of
material he just wins like piece after
piece after piece this was a fantastic
finish
no but it does block h7 whites control
of h7 check gary sacrifices our queen
check black has only one move he can't
move his king along the g file he has to
play 8 2 h7 white wins a bishop with
check only move white wins a queen with
check why not take just a second let me
see just a second so after this move
garyun the game took with the queen with
the bishop yes you wanted him to take
with the rook yes
okay let's just see why why he did not
do that torture him that's funny I like
that thought okay we can make a queen
which is kind of funny
and then the bishop would take it take
well if we take the rook with the rope
then he'll drop back and we'll be in a
Czech mating pattern this Bishop attacks
the king and this Knight defends these
two squares so we've got to be hmm
that's a very good question I'm trying
to I'm wondering what is black supposed
to do to stop this it's like uh that's a
good question
no in the game Gary just just took
everything off the board let's just see
how it finished so let me and we'll come
back to this because it's a very good
question and I don't mention it in my
book by the way Bishop takes so gary won
a bishop queen and rook just like that
and the game finished as we're about to
see right here this is where the game
ended
Karpov could have captured the bishop
but then after rook takes here would be
two exchanges behind as well as a few
ponds so now you've got me stumped you
did it Archer that would be funny sorry
rook takes g6 is what I want to see for
a second so now I've got to see Ben do
we have an engine on this
let me let me see the chess engine says
are you ready for this the chess engine
says okay so let me yeah
remove qubits ER for a moment the chess
engine says Queen okay so now the Queen
on b1 attacks the bishop so you can't
move the rook and make a checkmate
rather you'll have to take the Queen now
what the chess engine says is that now
you could move your knight attacking the
rook now it looks like it's checkmate
xkey but it looks like it's checkmate
but it's not you could block with the
knight but in this case by the way this
is even a more convincing victory than
the one chosen in the game so I like
rook takes g6 and the next time the new
copy the becomes a ha ha ha ha revise it
with the gravitation Tim well this game
really and it it really is marvelous
when you see like to the great players
of the world playing and giving it all
and there there was a ton of variations
and I didn't want to overwhelm overwhelm
you with where it was like White was
throwing the whole kitchen sink every
every piece and pawn that he had on the
board at blacks King and was being
successful this game at the time it was
played it won the best game of the year
and Gary won the world championship
thanks to this